Sci-Fi movies and books depict a future
with sentient machines capable of
interacting with humans and Performing
tasks just like people would what if we
told you that this future is already a
reality all of this is already made
possible by Machine learning machine
learning is a science of programming
machines to think and act like humans
without being specifically programmed to
we already use machine learning in our
daily life without knowing it email spam
recognition spell check even the YouTube
video recommendation which brought you
here are implemented using machine
learning machine learning uses
algorithms to learn tasks these
algorithms are fed with data from which
they learn to perform these tasks this
means that over time as changes in data
occur we don't need to reprogram our
application just let it find patterns
and learn from the new data machine
learning is a subset of artificial
intelligence which is a science concern
with imparting human-like intelligence
onto machines and creating machines
which can sense reason act and adapt
deep learning is a sub-branch of machine
learning which is inspired by the
working of the human brain machine
learning is leading us to a future where
machines can learn and think and has
opened us a whole new plethora of job
opportunities
this was a brief intro to machine
learning if you like this video do give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
simply learned channel for more content
like this don't forget to hit the Bell
icon to receive notifications what do
you think machine learning will be
capable of in the near future let us
know in the comments till then stay safe
and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign